[Music]
the i-team is digging deeper into
election security they found even with
millions of votes cast in our elections
voter fraud is still extremely rare
the i-team's david charns is live at
boulevard mall one of the
valley's early voting sites and david
what did you find out
well denise starting at nine tomorrow
morning anybody across clark county can
come here to this tent
outside the mall and cast their vote or
drop off their mail-in ballots
we've gotten so many questions over the
past couple days about election security
what to do if you get somebody else's
ballot
so i did some digging i wanted to know
about election fraud how this happens
and most importantly
if anybody can get away with it
nearly 2 million ballots will be cast in
nevada this election whether in person
or through the mail
so how secure can it be the i-team has
received several calls from viewers
who've received someone else's ballot
even for a person who's died frequently
we find out that someone moved
by uh sending the mail and and having
someone call us and tell them that they
no longer live there or we have the mail
returned to us as undeliverable
dan kulin of the clark county elections
department says even if someone were to
try to vote with someone else's ballot
they wouldn't succeed instead they'd be
slapped with a felony
we have security measures in place
to make sure that the voter that the
ballot is assigned to is the one that's
casting that ballot the i-team compared
data from the white house and the state
we found out of more than 7 million
votes cast in nevada elections since
2008
just two of those votes were cast
illegally
it was done by the same person in both
the 2008 and 2010 elections
she was not in the country legally step
right there
in another case roxanne rubin tried to
cast a second vote at a different
polling place in 2012 but poll workers
didn't allow her to
she later agreed to a plea deal and
admitted guilt in exchange for a lesser
charge
over the past 12 years there's been six
voter fraud convictions in nevada
but no cases of double voting or mail
fraud getting through the system
so probably the most important thing you
can do right now to keep your ballot
safe
is to sign the back as we've reported
that signature
needs to match and if a ballot doesn't
have a signature it won't be counted
we've gotten so many great questions
from viewers about
ballots and how to vote we've set up a
section on our website that we're
calling elections 101 we
answer some of the basic questions for
you you can find that right now on eight
newsnow dot com also
inside our app for now live outside
boulevard mall i'm david charns